most people have goals in life and we
were broke think you got to be
goal-oriented that's the first mistake
the what if I can pull off a miracle
what if I can become someone that no one
thinks I can be you will be told your
whole life that you need to learn to
listen I would say that you need to
learn to be the last to speak
what's that believe nation it's heaven
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something and I want you
to find it embrace it and use it to make
a difference now I started to believe
life series too once a week tackle a
topic outside of just hardcore business
instead of help you live your best
believe life today we're gonna look at
ten rules to win at life enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one build discipline with Will Smith
dude
screamed to me the other night hey will
I want to be active man I won't be
active just like you
you know usually people say stuff to me
like that I'm like yeah man you know you
doing give them an encouraging word but
I was just sitting here thinking and it
dawned on me 99% of people that say
stuff like that are not willing to do
what it takes to make their dreams come
true
the Marines have a saying everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die and that's just real at the
center of bringing any dream into
fruition is self-discipline you know
something something as simple as food
and eating it is not about your body as
much as it is about your mind it's
getting command of your mind to be able
to choose actions that are in your own
best interest every day we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you in the
world's trying to hold you down so
you're gonna kick yourself in the balls
so you will stop yourself from getting
what you dream self-discipline is the
center of all material success you
cannot win the war against the world if
you can't win the war against your own
mind rule number two
do not play safe with Elon Musk one of
the most difficult choices I have ever
faced in life was was in 2008 and I
think I had a good maybe thirty million
dollars left thirty or forty one dollars
left in 2008 I had two choices I could
put it all into one company and then the
other company would definitely die or
split it between the two companies and
but if I split it between two companies
then both might die and you know when
you put your blood sweat and tears into
creating something a bully something
it's like a child
and so it's like which one am I gonna
let one starve to death I can bring
myself to do it surprise I split the
money between two fortunately thank
goodness they both came through rule
number three a venture outside your
comfort zone with Richard Branson it
looks like you always go out of your
comfort zone right coming onto an island
that was completely deserted
no fresh water you don't even have the
money to buy it and and now you're
sleeping on a tent on the beach trying
to figure out how to get fresh water
here you do that often you did it with
the airline I mean I was just somebody
that experienced the bad experience of
traveling on airlines I was actually
trying to get to the BVI the British
Virgin Islands one day from Puerto Rico
and the same lovely lady was waiting for
me and I've been away for three weeks
and American Airlines bumped the flight
and and so I went to the back of the
airport I had a plane I had a blackboard
I wrote Virgin Airlines one-way $29 to
the VV I went around all the people have
been bumped and I filled my first plane
and and that got me thinking of airlines
do bump people they don't care about you
or me particularly in the air and so we
and so I then rang up Boeing and said
you have any second 747 okay I mean it
was literally that you just sat in the
airport and said I'm starting an airline
right now we cannot frustrate it exactly
and I think most most of the best
entrepreneurial ideas come out of
frustration I think you know if you if
you're frustrated about something and
the best way of sorting it out is get
out and do it and you've got yourself a
business rule number four compared only
to your yesterday's self with Jordan B
Peterson rule 4 compare yourself to who
you were yesterday and not to who
someone else is today because if you're
comparing yourself to someone else I
mean first of all you don't know very
much about the life of the person you're
comparing yourself to you don't know it
you know it across all of its dimensions
and second people are very different and
so comparing yourself to someone else
it's it's kind of useful I guess when
you're young but as you get older and
more singular and more
particular it becomes increasingly less
useful better to compare yourself to a
previous version of yourself and work
for improvement in that way rule number
five never quit with David Goggins I
would like to know when you're in that
moment failing mm-hmm and you have to
keep going what do you say to yourself
what if a lot of times I'll be the tours
at Mile Run or something like that and
I'm all jacked up body's broken mines
broken spirits broken I started to say
what if I can pull this off
when I first walked into the Navy SEAL
recruiters office he looked at me and
said only been 35 african-americans and
70 years make it through you know I said
to myself what if I can be the 36 it's
the what if I can pull off a miracle
what if I can become someone that no one
thinks I can be and just that just means
talking about that I have the hair
growing up on my arms because it makes
me just like what if I can be that guy
that people who call [ __ ] and this and
that and now I'm speaking at tom ferry
event what is
that's it rule number six be the last to
speak with simon Sinek
Nelson Mandela is a particularly special
case study in the leadership world
because he is universally regarded as a
great leader you can take other
personalities and depending on the
nation you go to we have different
opinions about other personalities but
Nelson Mandela across the world is
universally regarded as a great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief and he was asked one day how did
you learn to be a great leader and he
responded that he would go with his
father to tribal meetings and he
remembers two things when his father
would meet with other elders one they
would always sit in a circle and to his
father was always the last to speak you
will be told your whole life that you
need to learn to listen I would say that
you need to learn to be the last to
speak I see it in boardrooms every day
of the week even people who consider
themselves good leaders who may actually
be decent leaders will walk into a room
and say here's the problem here's what I
think but I'm interested in your opinion
let's go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard it
give me it gives everyone else too the
ability to feel that they have
contributed and two you get the benefit
of hearing what everybody else has to
think before you render your opinion the
skill is really to keep your opinions to
yourself if you agree with somebody
don't nod yes if you disagree with
somebody don't nod no simply sit there
take it all in and the only thing you're
allowed to do is ask questions so that
you can understand what they mean and
why they have the opinion that they have
you must understand from where they are
speaking why they have the opinion they
have not just what they are saying and
at the end you will get your turn it
sounds easy
it's
not practice being the last to speak
that's what Nelson Mandela did rule
number seven set clear goals with Joe
Rogan your life would feel better and
richer if you had a goal you chased that
goal you accomplished some things and
you would get this boost of confidence
you get this boost to self esteem like
whatever it is that you're going to do
maybe you're in a drawn comic books
maybe you're into nah but making pottery
or sculptures or but fine
whatever the that is and pursue that
instead of doing nothing like the people
that are doing nothing those are the
real people look doing something might
be as simple as like that Alex Honnold
guy he just climbs rocks but he's
world-class rock Delilah it's something
rule number eight have a vision for your
life with Jordan Belfort most people
have goals in life and we would Brooke
thing you got to be goal-oriented that's
the first mistake yes you need goals but
there's something far beyond goals which
is what all successful people have and
that's a vision it's a vision for the
future see the here's it is you see
things as they are but not worse than
they are
yeah which is what a lot of people do
yeah they say oh it's so terrible they
tell themselves this wild story about
why they can't take action and in truth
the story they tell themselves is
exactly what holds them back from being
successful okay it's that bull story
that stops from acting like and they're
all just some of the economy and they
play the blame game they complain they
justify and it stops them from moving
forward so see things as they are not
worse than they are you know and then
see them better than they are
yeah and make them that way look at a
Gandhi right he survived hunger strikes
in the United the country not because he
had a goal for free and yet he had a
vision of a free India Nelson Mandela
all those years in jail on vision yeah
it's Richard Branson who's a friend of
mine though I know he sponsors me my
speaking to her he's a good visionary
Bill Gates they're all visionaries and
the best example consider we're in
Hollywood is a guy like James Cameron
now here's the trap James Cameron is
probably the greatest visionary of all
time in filmmaking that we do a great
there he was a food on Diane Sawyer and
they asked him a question of what do you
owe your success to and what he said was
this I said
really really high goals so even if I
fall short I'm still doing great and
people thought that was pretty profound
and I actually believed in that too it's
not true though see what's happening is
this James Cameron it's not a goal
setter he's a visionary he just doesn't
realize because he's running unconscious
strategy himself
you said the try said of James Cal is a
really just the goals your vision for
avatar he'd say oh of course I will did
get all excited me tell you how nothing
was gonna stop him from making this
movie the fact that it took ten years
and ran 200 million over budget he put
money in himself or that's not what goal
setters do bowl setters will set a goal
gets tough and they abandon it and I
can't overemphasize that distinction
that's number one is vision rule number
nine read more with Tai Lopez the fact
that people argue with me on this
reading thing and people argue with me
about mentors no just use your own gut
feeling is that how you learn English
when you were two years old you use your
gut feeling to start conjugating verbs
no you learn from other people you learn
manners you learn language you learn all
things valuable you learn to drive from
another person so it doesn't make sense
you learn life so books are just the
mentors who maybe are dead now you wanna
learn about Steve Jobs you ain't alive
to teach you but you can learn through
accumulated wisdom and that's what trust
me
I've meet I very few powerful
businessman I've ever met don't read a
lot Warren Buffett who I think's the
best businessman by far in the world
because done see has 75 companies that
he pretty much runs 200 billion in
revenue he reads eight hours a day
he reads 600 he said he slowed down in
his old age he only reads 500 pages a
day Bill Gates goes on reading vacations
Mark Zuckerberg just start started a
reading once a week book club on
Facebook and already got a couple
million far and now with audiobooks
there's no excuse you got YouTube videos
let this thing run in the background
like you want to become like a
supercomputer you just download smart
crap from smart people and you pick and
choose like some people are like Thai I
don't agree with everything you say I'm
like good I don't agree with everything
I say like a year later I'm like wait I
was wrong and rule number 10 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
be grateful with Oprah Winfrey close
your eyes
for a moment will you please and breathe
with me just close your eyes and if you
will put your thumb to your middle
finger and gather your other fingers
around and let's feel the vibration and
pulse of your personal energy as you
take three deep breaths with me inhale
and as you exhale just feel the
vibration energy blood pulsating through
your body through you and another inhale
and another inhale and keep your eyes
closed and let's just think about this
day this day that you have been graced
to breathe in and out thousands of times
this day where many of those breasts
were taken for granted you just expected
the next one to come but the truth is
there's no guarantee that the next one
comes this day how you started your day
what your thoughts were this morning how
you've carried yourself through this day
how you've been allowed to have
encounters and experiences some
challenging some more life enhancing
that pushed you forward another day of
being here on the planet Earth as a
human being I just think about that
after all you've been through and this
day alone and the many days and years
passed how you got here to this
prestigious esteemed University the
choices you made that have brought you
to this
des open your heart and quietly to
yourself say the only prayer that's ever
needed thank you thank you
thank you you're still here and you get
another chance this day to do better and
be better another chance to become more
of who you were created and what you
were created to fulfill thank you
now I've got a really special bonus clip
with Mark Cuban on how to get it right
once but before that I want to know what
did you learn from this video what was
the single most important rule what
commitment are gonna make the change in
your life after watching this video
leave it in the comments when you write
it down it's much more likely to
actually happen so write it in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love see
you soon and enjoy the bonus clip
you just have to try different things
and even even if 99% of them fail you
only have to be right one time you don't
have to figure it all out in advance you
can be wrong you could pick the wrong
career you can pick the wrong job you
can pick the wrong spouse you could pick
the wrong whatever but you get it right
one time you're set but if you don't try
and if you don't go out there and try
all those different things you'll never
get that one time and so it's not a
question of okay how much stuff is
different stuff do I do or how many
different things should you try try them
all try them all till you find the one
you like and then it's like it gets
really easy because even when it's up
you're on a mission you're loving what
you do you know and then then it gets
easy and so that's just the approach
I've always tried to instill and people
who work for me and myself if you tell
yourself a story long enough you start
to believe it don't you believe it you
act like I have Tulsa what a wail out of
handcuffs lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad on the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for 250 four days I
will be sending you a video between 30
seconds and 5 minutes long that you
start your morning with around making
you feel confident it's absolutely free
check out the link in the description
below to get access